as it turns out when it comes to
degrading and dehumanizing and
mischaracterizing your opposition
and not taking the high road michelle
obama did plenty of that last night most
obvious example
she suggested that the trump
administration throws people in cages
okay so here she was last night
suggesting the trump administration
throws people in cages
they see our leaders labeling fellow
citizens
enemies of the state while emboldening
torture-bearing white supremacists
they watch in horror as children are
torn from their families and thrown
into cages and pepper spray and rubber
bullets
are used on peaceful protesters for
photo op
sadly this is the america that is on
display for the next generation
weird because of the america that was on
display for during your administration
was complete
utter chaos in ferguson missouri
complete utter chaos in washington
dc and baltimore so um yeah also i seem
to remember that you know where those
cages got started you know where they
got started those horrible horrible
cages um with
with barack obama i have some bad news
from the obama administration era
uh those cages began with forced
separation policy
promulgated by the ninth circuit court
of appeals they began under the obama
administration
which led to that famous botch where the
media started putting out a photo of
kids in cages that actually was from
the obama time but don't worry she take
she took the high road right there
and the the trump administration is only
using rubber bullets and tear gas
against peaceful protesters there are no
actual rioters in the streets they don't
exist they're gone but she's taking the
high road guys
very very high very very high road also
she says that the white house doesn't
care about black people
which is also taking the high road so
she says that there is a never-ending
list of black people who've been
murdered by the police a never-ending
list of black people murdered by the
police
um well actually according to the
washington post there are a grand total
of 15
black people who were killed unarmed by
the cops last year
15 so that seems like an ending list not
never ending it seems like mostly an
ending list
and in the vast majority of those cases
the people who are quote unquote unarmed
actually were either going for a cop's
gun or using some other type of weapon
to attack the cop
or were physically in an altercation
with a gop but apparently it's a
never-ending list and the white house
won't say black lives matter
the white house won't say black lives
matter because they don't want to mimic
the rhetoric of the actual black lives
matter movement because
the phrase black lives matter is a
semantic trap that has been laid by
democrats it is a semantically
overloaded term
right that is why the white house has
not used the term black lives matter
because it is unclear what it means i
mentioned this
several times it means one the utterly
unobjectionable idea that black lives
matter just as much as any other lives
in the united states
two the perfectly objectionable idea
that the united states is systemically
racist and that people are targeting
black people for death which is utterly
untrue
the vast majority of black people who
are killed in the united states are
killed by other black people just like
the vast majority of white people in the
united states who are killed
are killed by other white people okay so
that's a completely arguable idea and
then finally there's the completely
inarguable idea that you should not be
endorsing the black lives matter
organization
a radical awful terrible group okay but
she says that there's a never-ending
list again this is michelle obama who is
just the greatest
wisest mom mom is disappointed in us
that was the method that was sort of the
the message of this
because she's everybody's mom michelle
obama that's how she's portrayed by the
media
mom is disappointed in you and she's
disappointed in you because the white
house won't say that black lives matter
while endless
numbers of black people are being
murdered apparently by the system
which isn't true but she's going to push
that line anyway
as george floyd briana taylor
and a never-ending list of innocent
people of color
continue to be murdered stating the
simple fact that a black life matters
is still met with derision from the
nation's highest
office never ending list guys because
whenever we look to this white house for
some leadership
or consolation or any semblance
of steadiness what we get instead is
chaos division and a total and utter
lack of empathy okay then again it's
going to come back
time and time again to empathy and we're
going to blink very slowly for the
camera
lack of empathy and caring right that's
the shtick that's the shtick
is that trump should care now she's
never gonna mention the fact that there
are full-on riots in major american
cities that have taken more lives by the
way than the police took
of unarmed black americans last year
she's not going to mention any of that
she's not going to mention the complete
the complete looting of entire districts
of new york
l.a washington dc chicago you're not
going to mention any of that stuff
because it doesn't exist poof
it's just the trump isn't empathetic
that's the big problem here trump lacks
in empathy and it doesn't matter
that politicians pushing the lying
narrative that america is systemically
racist and targeting black people for
death
in endless numbers right there's a
never-ending list of black people
targeted for death by the cops
that is significantly more damaging to
america by the way but she says that
there's a never-ending list of black
americans being targeted by the cops is
significantly
more of a lie and more damaging to the
united states than donald trump
not saying the phrase black lives matter
because it's semantically overloaded but
she is going to pretend that this is all
just an issue of empathy and this is the
game the democrats love to play
if you disagree with them it's because
you're just not caring enough guys it's
cause you don't care and watch
i will show you how much i care cause
i'm gonna blink slowly right now you
ready one two three go
caring did you see it did you see the
carrying happening right there that
means that i know what's best for
america because i
have empathy facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content